coming up less than 10 currently 300
four players war zone open average
rating 1761 time is the handicap 30
minutes experience level 52 get in here
we go here we go I don't like start now
at a tournament I like a slower approach
this guy right here is the one that I
have that one last minute buzzer beater
and I think a one-minute they want to
draw I don't want to draw I want to win
I think in order to get first you need
to like win all your games so I'm okay
if they grab that okay they're not
grabbing that so what does this really
mean I think h4 could be good okay now
it's probably not a good idea I'm gonna
do this even though it looks ugly don't
do this
and then just crawl over here on Fe
everything's okay there's no Bishop h6
everything is gonna be alright it's
gonna be okay
run king 9700 that's a little scary
right there f7 coming under some heavy
heavy heavy fire okay let's watch over
f7 oh maybe I should have done 85 first
I want to get 85 in so my knight could
pivot on b6 okay here we go
these six to d5 incoming b6 to d5 I
could grab this pond what am i doing
okay that's a little scary I think they
might chop up this guy okay forget about
that double up light squares it's all
about the light squares double up double
up it's double trouble and I have to
sack pieces I have to go with this so I
could give check otherwise it'd be Queen
here and I end up losing stuff let me
get rid of this dark square Bishop is
this gonna be good I gotta get out of
this diagonal this is ridiculous
oh no I had this covered I have this
covered
how much time they have very little time
so that's a good thing it's a good thing
if your opponent has very little time
there's an obvious statement there's an
obvious one it's good if your opponent
has little time there we go they must be
nervous let's trade come on they're in
pins pins pins pins pins oh oh oh
their King must be scared I'm scared I'm
more scared than they are I wonder if
they realize that okay I'm okay with
giving that pawn up for some reason I
want Queen to g100 okay let's black my
queens are protected they only have 18
seconds here we go here we go let's
trade Queens let's trade Queens here we
go 13 seconds time burners I just want a
time burner no trade Queens never mind
give a check just burn their time check
how could I burn time they're in the pen
they're still in the pen give a check
come back scary it's very scary
Oh check stop mate
you're gonna give check with their night
that's not me it is it how much time how
much time just come back here oh what a
bad way to stop hurt oh why can't it
just be easy this guy's gonna give me a
beating he's gonna give me a beating
sometimes he offers me a draw to begin
I might accept it oh I should have
played that for okay this guy is he
gonna give me a beating he's probably
gonna give me a beating f4 can I get
that in so is this still like um no it's
not it's not quite the same thing is it
I wasted some time there I definitely
definitely wasted some time there okay
we've been here before but I am I'm
gonna accept their drop there they're
evenly rated maybe I should have
accepted that draw earlier okay I also
wasted some time on that too so okay
hopefully that one doesn't come back to
bite me okay
well that's different I want to get d5
in d5 let's go for it right now before
it's maybe oh space advantage the space
advantage this bishop is dead isn't it
it's a dead guy dead bishop for as long
as I maintain that structure they're
gonna try and break it down recaptured
the knight hit the Queen and recapture
with the Queen it takes I'm on the
rookie the rookie Rookie
the Knights gonna move I could give
check oh okay I'm on g2 if they take I
could take the pawn if they push they
might push they might be scared here
what's going on
Trix Oh what am i doing I have a dark
square bishop okay let's get out of that
let's get out of that and flight squares
flight square out of here okay
create a little bit maybe it'll take now
I'll just do that that was just being
too sneaky I'm not getting anything out
of this nothing oh the rook is just
gonna play here why not why didn't the
Rope just play there what is my quick do
something queen you're stupid over here
on the H file
you're stupid over there check check
just drop back okay
can I win this can I win it stop the
knight from doing stuff put it in a pin
trade somepony's trade some pawns
there we go oh wait a second wait a
second what are they I'm there in time
I'm there in time
stop that pawn bishop let's go King
let's go King oh man okay okay okay okay
let's do this
and then
it's push they want to draw I don't want
to draw I want to win are they gonna run
out of moves they'll run out of moves
right one day won't they
there we go now the bishops gonna go
into pacman mode
pac-man mode gobble them up oh hang on
gobble here push push this is a winner
just take that guy there we go
take this guy come on you should be
resigning
you should be resigning this man they're
making me play this one out okay got it
27 that's what I'm talking about how can
you beat over 27 22 and change okay that
second game was just a what zero time I
have to employ the fishing fishing
fishing fishing fishing I need to get
one win with the fishing pole some
variation of that come on you know you
want a castle okay okay this is decent
this is this is good stuff get more
checks man
I don't even know what that's doing why
did I do that of all things why did I do
that one why'd I do that that was so
stupid
oh I'm dropping f2o it's very scary
it's what you call very scary right here
I'm gonna play King to f1 even though
there's possibilities for discover
checks I want to have Queen h4 and then
qing-ge to Wow
okay and they're stopping that I could
throw in a check it's row in a check
take on d5 f7 f 7o f7 f7 f 7 Rick f8
okay fade is nice my cafe is really
really nice run King oh oh man I missed
that one oh I missed that one defend I'm
in trouble I'm in trouble oh it's very
scary it's very very scary here
scary town everything better be defended
I can't do any better
I got Bishop check Bishop check get that
in on g5 and maybe the tables turn I'm
looking to turn the tables Bishop g5
whoa what's the trick
what's the trick there's no trick
there's Knight check and then this
Bishop is picked off 94 everything is
okay maybe that was a mouse lip maybe
they meant d6 and they're kicking
themselves now they're in pins pin City
Queen f7 is a threat whoa okay
everything's alright defend I'm on the
bishop I'll come back to block a check
on d3 and okay okay now everything is
okay they're in the pen the smoke is
cleared my king is safe everybody's
happy everybody's happy now
team white team white give a check push
upon push
again hide keep pushing keep pushing
keep pushing keep pushing here we go
this is Maysoon isn't it
check where is the quick mate
quick mates check mate there we go back
to Chairman 12 Wow 12 a big 12 right
here
Oh CW CW with CMS so s okay get rid of
that this is my expendable bishop these
are the expendable one get rid of them
occupy the weak point okay get ready to
kick this guy away
maybe my bishop on d6 is better let's
play now let's get that clean out there
good versus bad bishop positions good
versus bad bishop chop get on f5 you
know you want to be there Knight f5 is
where you belong check and then trade
Queens I love a clean trade there's
gonna be a pawn push okay that's a
little bit scary or a lot scary I'm
gonna drop a pawn just to make sure my
king is gonna be alright okay okay okay
let's take care just to secure the King
position that's what it's all about
secure it secure that King position
secure the knight position there might
be an exchange sack so I don't want that
I like my rook activity better so let's
go on this side and everything is nice
and cozy cozy position do we have a cozy
position here whoa let's play over here
since that's locked up and maybe my king
wants to okay now let's trade a little
bit more I want rook activity I have
very little time though let's go hit the
bishop weasel my king around we're okay
here we go going after the apon going
after that apon now he's dead the a pine
is cooked my Knights in a pin I don't
need to move them down do i okay
tick tick tick I'm not getting
any quick wins where are the quick wins
they're non-existent non-existent give a
check here and I don't even know what
that's doing come on King help out do
something do something King be a
contributor they're gonna fall for it
there it is
Bishop killer Bishop resignation or not
there's no resignation come on check
check
King position come on this is beat this
is definitely beat
it's the rook we're even on time yes
back to tournament 5346 33 30 30 26
Roger that one Roger that Roger 54 days
Roger 54 days two minutes and change is
Roger moving Roger Roger
let's go Oh Roger is not moving an on
mover Roger okay let's go and see what's
going out with the leader the right
here's the leader let's do some homework
homework time what is the leader play
and efore oh the leader just won again
and my game is still what okay here he
goes he's going at it again 69 points
Wow my part my player has a disconnected
that's the word and they're experiencing
the same thing here
they're experiencing a disconnect er
okay
so what do you do you go to another
leader I'm dropping back I'm in tenth I
just want the top ten this guy right
here is playing my game is still not
going a minute left for my game games
games games this one this guy right here
is up there
what does this guy play this guy plays D
3 e 5 G 3 D 5 that's a weird one start
out with D 3 and then G 3 so what's that
like Kings Indian attack formation
ah I'd much rather be playing then
checking up these games here ah ok all
right well who's gonna win this one
probably ok yeah white just one there
out the rook close out of that
ok less than 20 seconds I am going to
hang around here and let's see how much
there's only there's less than 14
minutes ah I only have a 20 how many
points will I gain with this win 30 or
30 total we're gonna see back the
tournament back to the tournament Holly
I only have 30 here we go 13 and change
Peter ping can I score a quick one just
want a win real quick real quick win
accelerated something accelerated here
f5 f5 Bishop h6 seen it before
woah they are crazy they have to be
crazy right there's no way you could
give up that dark square Bishop and not
take a beating let's see if that's the
case my bishops gonna get trapped
looking for a tricky stuff I'm looking
for tricky stuff I'm on the rook if the
rook moves it's a mountain to move rook
yes just resigned there's no way to stop
Maine just resign Peter Peng
come on don't let that clock tick no way
no no man I'm getting Peter pegged they
want to draw yes okay back to tournament
oh that was a little bit quick right
there bumping up bumping up the ranks
here we go get that out of there double
those points sicilian sicilian land open
Sicilian land Queen c7 here we go I'm
setting it up setting it up setting it
up I'm on the bishop things are pretty
I'm on h2 if they take I'm still on h2
if they don't take they didn't take me
that's what I'm talking about
87 6259 5600 here we go this guy is
having a good tournament he's having a
good tournament let me see if I could um
mess with that let's see if I could mess
with this guy having a good tournament
Oh
getting ready for Knight g4 yeah already
494 I'm gonna do this anyhow Knight g5
Knight G fives okay I'm still gonna do
it
although oh boy this is a little scary
are they gonna beat me like I beat my
last opponent I'm in a fork at the very
least Knight right here is nice that's a
good one
that is a good one but maybe I could
still be getting something good against
f7
okay then yeah g3 maybe one day g3 I'm
gonna be in check okay or not so this is
an interesting position Wow what do you
do what does one do
let's do I don't know what I want to do
okay let's play here I just want to win
haha I just want to win is that too much
to ask okay now my knight has a cozy
home on f4 that's nice I don't even know
what that move does oh boy oh boy oh boy
let's get out of pins let's get out of
pins it's guard the seventh rank guard
that seventh rank and I'm gonna be
chased away anyhow this is really scary
really really scary right here okay
hopefully this works hopefully this
works it's not gonna work it's not
working oh it just can't be easy can it
nope nope nope nope odd push is good
pawn push would have been pretty good I
don't have anything I'm dead what does
that even do take my knight I'm getting
made it somehow I'm getting mated oh
look at this would you look at this haha
Oh beads I'm dropping a bishop and
everything oh it's not happening hit the
resign button just hit the resign button
and go cry in the corner oh I could
still leave me get top ten I'm at 54
that was horrendous horrendous I tell
you ah alright you could do this don't
you dare to start thinking about giving
up
the more pep talks given more pep talks
okay watch out for d6 it's a little
scary it's a little scary that d6 square
get out of their night I want to win a
pond oh okay alright
b5 Bishop b7 keep it closed over here I
need some more development don't you
dare try to open up the position when I
am lagging in development here my knight
would absolutely love to get to the C 3
square he's gonna be one happy piece
hang on though hang on
I don't want to deal with pins I don't
want to deal with pins get out of there
night get out of there
here we go here we go the night is gonna
be an excited piece very soon he's
excited he's excited connected passed
pond trouble hit the Queen light square
weaknesses trade a queen improve the
king position get my king here get the
King up get them up get them up get them
up be for King position my knight is
really strong on c3 push connected
passed pawns too connected passed pawns
g5 oh oh man
okay let's go with man let's do this
trouble this is trouble for me it's a
little scary it's definitely scary Tom
in check oh I'm in check
hang on they're trying to check me
around pawn push is a threat
is everything okay if I do this please
it's okay please say it's okay rook
check King here everything is okay and
winning now because that connected
passed pawn is very valuable I insist I
want control of this
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go
you gotta take you gotta take are your
dead real soon and now you got to defend
um let's go over here I think this is
the right idea let's go oh that's a win
that's a winner right there isn't it so
when I'm going after the b3 pawn going
after b3 and then there's connected
passed pawns you're not gonna be able to
defend that okay not gonna be able to
defend that one push push and then get
rid of the blockade er get rid of that
blockade er resignation come on resign
resign resign resign
let's go chop a rug come back here oh
that was stupid what's stupid of me
oh man and they're still playing on
let's go here chop get over here okay
stop that pond
oh my mouse is stupid stupid Mouse there
we go
push push keep pushing there's no way to
attack my rug
come on you know this is beat rag here
we go 121 13 105 one or two ninety
seventy seven seventy oh okay I need you
know what I need quick wins here and
there not quick this guy's going to kill
me in one move just take that pun just
take that pine hopefully I get the Queen
I'm gonna get the Queen I'm looking for
tempo games tempo gains tempo gain more
tempo gainers tempo gainer
back on e to watch over f2 more tempos
where is the King gone Knight g5 of King
here rook e8 and then mate looking for
me
sumin pin a knight Bishop here one of
these two g6 leads to matin
am i doing where's the quick main night
here could be good or not here not here
is good night here is good night here's
real good
here we go deflection oh no I just
couldn't make it
I had a quicker main just Queen there
immediately ah okay is it still there
it's still there it's still there Bishop
h6 and then it's me queen mate here we
go
I had that earlier as soon as the biz
the pond pushed back to tournament when
we got oh I'm in 8th I'm in 8th I'm in
8th well the three and change 125 120
113 five people in the hundreds 96 okay
alright alright alright Sicilian quick
resigned
okay let's do it
push pieces around they should be seven
okay let's get a good Center let's get a
good center and then run away scared for
just a little bit for just a little bit
we'll run away shut down that Bishop my
bishop looks foolish right here he's a
foolish Bishop okay maybe I could take
advantage of this Bishop being
unprotected here we go this is what I
was talking about chop chop chop more
chops right here mmm I'm going to allow
that pod to be taken just to open up the
position gonna take my other bishop
oh man that's I gotta get rid of that
night there's no way I could deal with
oh that's a good move actually I could
take the bishop now okay I'm on this
night twice to with my with my dark
square bishop I didn't realize that
initially okay now let's just take here
get rid of that one piece that's in my
territory now this bishop is free to
move along the diagonal take like this
my rook is protected I could take that
night I want to push my pawn let's just
do this watch over it
rook here might be good yeah actually
it's gonna be good yeah matin one threat
f2 back to tournament 108 one in change
135 135 what do we have what do we have
what do we have 135 einsteinium Zee
einsteinium Zee okay we have been here
before I think Oh back to tournament
quick resigner 128 a 1 and change 116
116 this one's not gonna finish they can
always let the time
each pond each pond oh they are running
scared
they're running scared they're giving me
a file to play oh I might want to smash
that open I might want to smash it open
hit the Queen No Wow what I want to do
that why would I want to give my
opponent free pieces okay okay let's do
this
and then get my queen up clean up get
rid of the light-square bishop quickly
very quickly here we go here we go here
we go here we go
take that bishop get away night I wanna
should have backed up should have backed
up here we go smash it open
I don't have enough fuel no phew nothing
and my nights hanging over here oh it's
hanging over here defend it and there's
rook check and it's just not happening
folks it's not happening just take this
and just hope for the best
it's already complete it's game over
turn them it over I mean come on just
let it finish save me save me yeah and
so take it
Oh six big crowns okay Oh what do we got
160 155 153 130 128 122 116 went away a
lot of hundreds Marana
Moran er had a good one good games oh
okay whoo